so our next guest this afternoon is
magnus carlsen who just defeated etienne
barco by 2-0
were you expecting this uh choice of
opening by your opponent
uh no i was was a bit surprised but i
think it was uh was a good choice since
he got a comfortable position
uh afterwards i think i yeah i responded
kind of meekly uh and uh
i uh yeah i was i was a little bit worse
for sure
okay so of course it's hard to know
exactly what european was thinking but
it seemed to me that
maybe he missed the 97 idea in the in
the in the main line
and specifically what were you ex what
were you preparing to do if you're
playing queen g4
yeah um i sort of missed some
some details before i went h4 myself
which is
uh it's it's an ugly positional move but
i kind of want
i want to play e5 and sort of clarify
everything
um and he yeah so he took an e4
believing i had to take back um almost
i'm almost completely sure he missed uh
he missed 97 because you
never you never allowed that um yeah so
if he goes queen g4 queen e6 one of
those so
i'll um exchange rooks go queen f7
queen e6 and exchange and
i thought there were very good winning
chances but
most of all i'm never ever losing it of
course so that was already
i felt like i was already playing with
house money uh
then and then we made a couple more
moves he
took an e7 he i took back uh
and he played knight five rookie two and
he played knight d4 and offered me a
draw um
and it was a bit too late yeah
i didn't hear that but that's a surprise
obviously maybe maybe for that
i mean i understand that i win the match
but uh
by by accepting that i thought my
position was
just too winning so i uh
i mean in general you don't decline
these offers but
i just thought there was just no way i
was losing it and
it's nice to pick up the win of course
now you'd like semi-finals you got two
free days until
the next game what do you plan to do
these two days oh first of all i
desperately need them
i think everybody needs them but yeah
now i've played eight days in uh
in a row and i could really really feel
it today that i had
zero energy um so i intend to
go for a hike in the mountains probably
um try and relax
and just you know be glad for two things
that i don't have to play for a couple
of days and
most of all that i'm still in the
tournament okay congratulations and
i now also i know that i will be here to
the end
regardless might as well might as well
drive minutes appreciation thank you